i spoke to like some people who are like
yeah it's ax good i'm planning to go
alone i'm like do not go to ax alone
yeah
i was like define good i'm like you
probably go to a local con alone and
probably make sure yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah like
nyx like everyone already has their
group with them yeah so it's like
like you don't have enough time to hang
out with the group that you have
already right let alone hanging out with
like randomers you know what i mean
yeah [ __ ] yeah i just had like so many
flashbacks if we're hanging out with
random people that were terribly wrong
because okay you've all been there right
everyone goes to convention right yeah
yeah
you know you've got to decide i really
want to go to this convention
but [ __ ] hotel rooms are expensive right
so it's like
how many people can i fit in this hotel
and to reduce it to a point where i'm
comfortable right
like and i think we said this on my
podcast where like if you're the
if you're in charge of the booking yeah
you get dibs on the bed right
so that's why i always used to be in
charge of the bookings i'm like i'm
getting the bet yeah i'm getting the
best bet
i don't get it before oh my god when
if the hotel doesn't ask you how many
keys you want it's like
there's two keys between six of you and
it's like how do we how how do we
distribute and we decide who gets a key
yeah
like like the key has the power
yeah yeah yeah it's like because you can
come and go as you want because there's
nothing worse than just sitting there
with all your bags
being like calling up your mate yeah not
[ __ ] picking up and you're like i
want to go back to the hotel room
answer me you can't like mobile service
in the convention is [ __ ]
god it's non-existent it's not existing
you just basically gotta
you basically gotta pretend you're back
in like the [ __ ] 18th century you're
like how do i contact joey especially
when you're in america
we don't have american phones either oh
like i have a contract on my british
phone that gives me american service
which is
usable in most places but
in like a convention you are getting
like zero [ __ ] services
like it's like a [ __ ] greek marathon
right you have to like ask someone to
like can you run to the other side of
the convention and tell joey that i'm
here
it's like i'll see you soon have you
ever stayed in a room with people who
you're like
[ __ ] i regret staying in a room with
them uh yeah
well i'm not gonna name names you can't
name your name all right phone
i can't name my names yeah but
i mean you stayed with some discord
people right yeah i stayed there with a
bunch of people on discord
and that always goes well [ __ ]
nightmare that sounds like a nightmare
[ __ ]
i was like the pseudo leader of the
group right um
and there's just so many [ __ ]
problems and this is also when i just
started youtube and i hadn't like i i
hadn't formally met
i met you no i'd met sydney yeah didn't
get to see you
but we were going to hang out we really
planned to and i hadn't met you yet how
did i
i don't think so so this was kind of
like i don't know i wasn't going to make
mates you know with you i was planning
to hang out with you guys for the
majority
oh was this the first ax this is the
first day when you spend most of your
time with us
yeah i remember that so i had told the
people i was staying with
like hey this is like straight up just
like a room thing like i'm gonna be
hanging out with other people like for
like 99 of this totally
many times i think like one of them
like didn't quite get the memo and he
was like really hoping that i would
introduce him
to like everyone and all right yo he's
my best mate
he's hey and the problem was
is uh he was a [ __ ] creep so like i
didn't really want to hang out with him
yeah yeah um
and uh it wasn't like at first he was a
little
strange you know he was an american and
he was like a military dude
and in my experience military dudes are
like 50 50 on whether they're like
totally chill or just [ __ ] psychotic
i i i actually totally agree i've i've
met so many military dudes
and there is no in-between there's no
between either they're a [ __ ] psycho
or they're the most cheerless
you could have ever ever everywhere i've
met it's always like that it's like
no like no chill yeah so he's like kind
of nice you know he's
whatever he's a little weird and then
like one time i remember i met
you at a party and then like he was
texting me the whole time and i think i
mentioned where i was
yeah as we're leaving this party do you
remember this like yeah i remember this
we we go outside and he's waiting there
at like one a.m he's like hey connor how
you doing man can i join
and we're like getting an uber and i'm
like uh no man we're getting an uber
somewhere else
i'm really sorry man because like it's
like how do you introduce it's like kind
of creepy yeah yeah
yeah everyone's already seen that he's
waiting outside and it's really creepy
and yeah
it's the over enthusiasm right because
the thing about anime conventions that's
so difficult for a lot of people to like
wrap their heads around is just like
what what is socially acceptable because
you know what i mean
like social rules are thrown out the
window when you don't know someone i
think it's like a social
rule where you shouldn't be bringing
your friends in like yeah unless you
have like a reason to
yeah but if you if you if you don't like
okay because if you bring someone in to
a friend group
and that guy's an [ __ ] or a creep
that's not that's unusual
yeah and i didn't know him and i i got
kind of
science that he was a creep yeah yeah
and so i didn't want to bring him in
because i was like if i bring him to
this party and he starts like [ __ ]
chatting up giggles all night like hey
man i love your videos can we take a pic
and i smell your penis like you know
what i mean it's like
it's like kind of looks terrible on me
so i was like and the party was at my
house
or my airbnb and there was like anything
like ten of us so it was really intimate
so i told him i was like listen
i'm really sorry dude but like i i i
don't really know like gone or like
anyone in this group pretty well like
i would invite you i just don't feel
like comfortable doing it i explained to
him and he was so pissed off
and uh just pissed off you're so pissed
off so then
i came back at like 5 a.m to my shitty
hotel in like uh it's the like suburbs
of l.a right
it was it was like koreatown wasn't it
uh no it's further away it's like
even like it was really far out and it
was really sketchy it was like uh
what was it called it wasn't even like a
holiday and it was one of the even the
more budget changes like this hotel
it was bad it was really bad and at this
hotel
for some reason at midnight all the
cards reset so if you came back after
midnight you'd go to the front desk
but the front desk wasn't open all right
so if you came back after midnight you'd
hope someone else is already in the room
or just wait out your door till 6am
until someone comes yeah it's stupid
so he was in the room and he'd been like
drinking alone
in his room and i felt really bad but so
i'm like hey man let me in let me in
whatever you know it's like 5am like
dude i really want to [ __ ] sleep so
he he opens the door and comes out block
oh [ __ ]
blocking the door so i couldn't get in
right i'm like yo what the [ __ ] man like
let me let me in
i want to sleep it's 5am and he's like
absolutely
hammered he's like listen connor i
thought you were cool man
party i'm like dude i'm like dude i'm so
sorry but like not now man it's 5am let
me see yeah yeah
yeah you talk about it in the morning
dude please let me sleep and then
whatever so we slept whatever finally i
let me in but i thought it was weird
that he i
was like i was ignoring him i'm not
trying to open the door he's blocking me
and i'm like the
[ __ ] man let me in it's five mm i paid
for this room let me sleep
and uh like near the end one of the
other
people's in my room who was like a lot
smaller and like
i i guess he thought they were cute and
then they called me up and he's like hey
uh he just tried to
pay me uh to suck his dick and i'm like
uh what the [ __ ]
uh what the [ __ ] i'm like what is
happening in this hotel
room yikes and then i was like i am so
[ __ ] glad i didn't introduce you to
any of my friends you're generally
asking people to suck your dick for
money are you kidding me
so needless to say uh i i went to the
hotel room just explained him like hey
what the [ __ ]
man don't do that you [ __ ] like yeah
this is my friend
don't make them uncomfortable and then
he didn't do anything and he went stayed
somewhere else like the last
night because i was like dude don't stay
in this room with them and so
i've never stayed with any random people
on discord that i've never met before
ever
i've heard so many horror stories from
discord i don't i don't know what it is
about discord
and i'm going to call it like the
discord hotel room yeah
those never ever go right
like i've because even like the best you
can do
is have like a little bit of drama but
there's never zero drama no nobody
nobody ever comes out there we're just
like yeah everyone was just chill
we had the most cheerless time everyone
was understanding what to say that
everything that's playing on discord
just ends up horrible
what is it about because you can't like
really know who's weird
on discord like the problem is that you
don't really know how weird people are
until you meet them
yeah yeah exactly you also it's it's
it's doubly true on discord as well
where you're here for this like you're
here for the server which is like
solely where you talk about this one you
know common interest or whatever
and you you rarely talk about your own
personality
i just don't understand the mentality
though of like looking at a discord
group and being like okay there's three
other people in here
never seen their faces i didn't care
because you've never met them before
i'm going to stay in a room with them
overnight it's like i was broke joey
what do you want from me
like what like at least like you know
hang out with them outside
i understand to all the convention guys
out there who have done the same thing
as me because you're broke as [ __ ] like
you got to do what you got to do and
plus
i knew i could take care of myself like
i know i'm fine like i didn't worry but
i
you know for when i hear like like 18
year old girls that do it and i'm like
whoa
with like with dudes i'm like that's
just that's just calling for a desire i
mean i mean like
it it's it's the it's a recipe for
disaster right because i've only stayed
in
i've already i've only gone to
conventions after i have had like uh
like after i had a full-time job so like
even even if it wasn't like a great
paying job at least i could just
afford my own hotel room and stuff like
that or like just a
really cheap motel room right you know
what i mean um but
if i had gone before i was like say 21
when i was just a broke uni student or
just god forbid
like like before even uni yeah like i
can imagine so many
horrible situations that could have
arose everything all right right
um which which kind of like no there's
no real way to protect yourself around
that especially if you're just
rooming with random people on discord
which is such a coin flip
you know and i would argue like is the
anime con really that worthless
yeah yeah honestly honestly you know
what all that weird [ __ ] that happened
aside that
i don't think i told you guys that ever
but yeah i mean
all of that weird [ __ ] the site that i
had to deal with yeah i [ __ ] do it
again
easy yeah but you [ __ ] do anything
i have i mean that was fun i mean
like the commitment i mean the
convention was fun yeah that was a
nuisance but yeah you know i mean it's
it's nice exercising knowing that i can
tell someone to [ __ ] off you know
i don't know what i mean it is what it
is i knew that when i
when i did that there was a chance that
it could go horribly wrong and it did go
horribly wrong and i learned my lesson
and i'm not doing that again yeah but he
said you would if you have the chance
no i mean i said i understand if you
know
when you're like 18 yeah you got like
200 bucks max to your name
right the [ __ ] ticket is 50 bucks you
got to get that hotel room down to 100
bucks somehow
it doesn't matter how many people got to
go in that room you you got to divide
the room with the amount of bodies that
will fit in it
if you need to sleep on the floor you
sleep on the floor people who
people who sleep in the bed they pay a
premium like a [ __ ] human trafficking
it
is a human have you ever been to a
[ __ ] convention room joey
jesus christ like like a [ __ ] bomb
could go up in there and it would be
less messy
than it is with just like the amount of
like if and if you've got a cosplayer in
there oh no
say goodbye to floor space say goodbye
to the [ __ ] floor for some reason
they are allergic to closing their
[ __ ] suitcase
it has to be wide open the whole [ __ ]
time can't close it okay
fine yeah i don't know i mean it's
whatever i
you should try sometime hanging oh thank
you i can afford my own hotel room
i'm good dude for the frills dude
[ __ ] roll that dice dude
okay i i don't know i like like i know
this sounds like super i guess it sounds
weird or dangerous some people i love
just
meeting new people in that kind of way i
mean look i don't mind meeting new
people
either but i don't mind being a new
person for the first time yeah
i don't want i don't want to pull a
gotcha role where i might end up you
know sleeping with a [ __ ] murderer
you know i don't get that i'll take that
off
you know you might get the [ __ ]
coolest friend for life by doing that
there's other ways to meet cool friends
for life man like you get that [ __ ]
story of we met in an anime
that's what i'm saying you'll do
anything for content i love
i love a [ __ ] like a true youtuber i
just know i don't even think of it as
content i just love like the idea of
like making a friend through such a
weird and unconventional way like
i feel like it makes such a good
friendship i don't know i mean again but
that's another coin flip though
i feel i feel like i'm somewhere in the
middle of both of you yeah because like
i
i do like meeting new people and
everything like that and i i used to be
that guy was just like up for anything
and i'd be like yeah i'll go
i'll go meet you down at like a dark
alleyway whatever but like
i've had like enough bad experiences to
be like you know what maybe i'll maybe
i'll do like a just a little bit of a
background check yeah before before
i do some research before i jump right
into it you know yeah
yeah oh my god yeah i've met so many
people on discord who turned out to be
really sketchy
yeah uh yeah yeah just gotta there's a
lot of dudes on on uh discord who like
underage girls and you just gotta call
that [ __ ] out when you see any signs of
it man yeah
i i feel like a lot of especially in
anime conventions a lot of people
especially obviously like anime you know
anime fans and weeds and everything
they don't have the confidence to
confront people when they see some [ __ ]
happening so
i feel like with a lot of convention
stories that i've heard it's it's mostly
bored down to
people just people just didn't know how
to handle the situation right because
they've never seen it happen
in front of them and so the first time
you experience it you just you kind of
just freeze up to be like what's right
is this is this happening now
is this is it something now you know
what i mean and no matter what you
tell yourself you're going to do at that
moment you you're totally unprepared for
that moment
so i would say like the best advice i
could give is if you see anything bad
happening
like don't let that [ __ ] lie call it out
also especially if they're your friends
like i know a lot of people
who are like it's hard to like you know
bollock your friend and be like dude
what the [ __ ]
but you gotta call that [ __ ] out yeah
it's like if you let it slide they'll
just keep doing it
we gotta stand this [ __ ] out of our
community because we saw what happened
to the smash community right and
i don't know what's happened behind the
scene of the anime community i mean
i i don't want to imagine it because i
yeah i wasn't part of the community
when some with some of the worst stories
i've heard happen behind the scenes
i mean yeah with like the seattle
youtuber that i used to do stuff with
and i've had people on discord who i
considered friends who later on found
out that they like did some [ __ ]
horrible stuff and like
honestly they were like you know there
were signs and i just ignored it because
i was like
oh well i mean i think you know they're
just quirky they're not gonna hurt
anyone yeah like you just gotta you
gotta call that [ __ ] out when you see it
unfortunately so if
your friend even if it's your friend
please call them especially especially
if it's a friend you know
only through the internet because you
know we i mean we all met through the
internet right
but i mean we've also met in real life
and we've hung out so many times before
i really
knew your guys's real personality and
everything like that right so if it's
some guy or some girl you've met through
the internet especially if you discord
something and you've
only talked to them through the internet
meeting friends making friends on the
internet is completely fine
but understand that that's totally
different
from being a friend irl and until you've
hung out irl
a few times you really can't have a true
grasp of their personality
and what they might be like and that's
why it's always such a gamble right like
when you
meet again like when you meet that
person on discord and then you
feel like all right let's go to a
convention together yeah and you're
hanging out with a completely different
person
yeah you know this is like oh you
weren't like this when we were chatting
on discord
what the [ __ ] like yeah and i've had a
lot of experiences like that where i
would be talking to someone online
and then i'd be like oh you're going to
ax oh i'm going to ax as well let's meet
up and hang out and then i talk to them
i'm like
wow um this
you weren't what i expected at all yeah
you are not the same person i texted
two days ago yeah [ __ ] for better or
worse
right sometimes they're way cooler in
real life sometimes they're just like
oof in real life and there's so many
social norms that
you like i i don't know like
i thought of all the dumb [ __ ] that
happened common sense just doesn't seem
to
like make sense like common sense just
isn't common in in anime conventions
right
especially when it comes to like meeting
people and stuff because you talked
about you talked about you know the
introducing the one friend to like your
friend group or something
what happens if you're like you're going
to this party right and you can be like
okay
you can you can bring like this one
friend that you might kind of want to
introduce
but they're with a group of like five
six people and they're like
um can you like get all these people in
as well
oh yeah and you're like what is it about
these people who are like oh plus one
also plus one group of friends all right
like
that's what it means yeah all right cool
i've got like seven people it's hard
because obviously you don't want to be
like yeah you know you
only one person can come in but yeah
you're also gonna have the balls your
son might be like all right mates
i've got a sick invitation from a guy
i'm gonna go to that i hope you all
understand yeah like that's what i would
be like i'd be like hey man i got an
opportunity that i don't really get
come across after yeah can i take it
please don't be mad at me yeah yeah
i think it's just understanding that
it's a convention people you know you're
not
you're not always going to hang out with
the same friend group
so i feel like if if if you have like
some other people you want to meet then
i feel like you just just
just let them go don't don't feel
betrayed by your friend hanging out with
other people or whatever